[Music]
today lecture gonna be on a world
championship history and I picked this
particular matchup from 1963 between
Tigran Petrosian and Mikhail Botvinnik
Botvinnik was the current champion and
Petrosyan was you know the candidate and
he wanted the candidate tournament and
basically this was his chance and if he
didn't win it that year maybe it would
never be a world champion but when it
was a champion for many years so and the
connection between Petrosyan because
he's also our minyan and me and i went
to his school named after Petrosyan so
was trained in that school my first
steps basically I made it in Armenia at
the Petrosyan school so that's how
everything started and the match was you
know 22 games total and does anybody
know who won the match and well you
probably know who won the match already
from the hint that Petrosyan won the
match well war was the final score of
this match No okay the match was won
twelve and half to nine and a half for
Petrosyan okay it was very difficult but
winning was very strong and his nickname
is chess encyclopedia it's extremely
knowledgeable he didn't play that much
but he would just analyze and analyze
and analyze and then he had a very
famous bottleneck chess school with a
lot of the top list Kasparov including
lot of players went to that school so it
was very very unethical place so
Petrosyan bought feeling both positional
players and the court of this match both
Winnick said after match that petrosyan
just analyzed the positions deeper his
understanding was maybe different that
he claimed he also understand the
positions with it but Petrossian
judgment of the position was deeper like
you know even simple positions he would
make it
deeper you know analyze it so that's
what the pitocin coated the match was
played in Russia Moscow and it was a
huge celebration when petrosyan won he
was a welcomed hero and everybody went
to a report to you know meet him and he
was and the moves in the moment he won
the back then there were no internet and
basically in the the center of Armenia
on a big demonstration board in a square
all the people gathered there like
thousands of people and then they had
this big demonstration important I guess
they would get the moves by telegraph or
something they would somehow get this
moves and they say the move and the guy
would go on with the big stick put the
move yeah you know anyway so it was
really you know very long match started
in March 23rd and went almost two months
I made 28 where petrosyan won the match
in 1963 and became a champion and it was
champion for a couple of years and both
Winnick didn't contest it you know he's
sort of you know retired you know played
after that you know match so he was
champion for a few years and this game
is game number five okay Petrosyan is
white against both Winnick c4 g6 night
of 693 do you know the name of this
opening or question is do we even know
which opening is this yet
number of things so more likely to or
three yeah but it's we don't know yet
it's on no one at the moment there are
two major openings can occur here
and depending on blacks third move we
will know the name of this opening so if
you place Bishop g7 that will be Kings
Indian defense and if you place the move
d5 which but winning did that is called
groom felt defense ok very sharp in
dynamic opening very popular nowadays so
Petrosyan was a player you know he
wouldn't go to the most sharp lines in
the opening now very conservatively try
to get some small advantage and nurse
disadvantage in to win more
conservatively III you know try to play
three just try to keep the position
protect it castles Bishop EQ actually
it's funny the system is still played
nowadays and you can still find some
strong players who will play like this
but not very proper this is definitely
not the most principled way to play
against groom fault so here many
different moves could be played is six
could be played which is decent c5 could
be played both vindictive so he's
forcing Petrosyan to move his Bishop
again to recapture the pawn anyplace c5
immediately keep in mind back in the day
63 the theory wasn't as deep as right
now now even you know not a grandmaster
players they know a lot of theory
because they just get chess based
program computer they start it's much
easier to get better in chess as long as
you have the dedication discipline and
you want to get better in chess if you
want to do that you want to put the time
into it you can get really good at chess
you know I mean it's it's easier because
there if the resources are accessible
you don't need like ten people working
for you back in the days the top players
they had a lot of people working for
them in like a team of four or five six
grandmasters because everything was just
analyzed by by hand by knowledge
everything was free
and a stack of paper and you know they
will go to tournaments take a whole
suitcase of books with them magazines
with them nowadays all I need is just a
laptop with updated version of all the
games and everything that's all you save
all your openings there so nowadays it's
the technology helped a lot to the chess
players so there everybody you know most
players they know a lot now
d5 now played very principled move by
Petrosyan to play d5 to get the control
okay so to get a control of the center
and now he advanced into opponents
position
so now d5 is played and if black doesn't
play anything concrete he will just
castle and play the movie four and he
will have a nice advantage a six
immediately played by both Vinick trying
to attack the center now what do you
think I should do here how he should try
to react here how he should try to react
here
Castle yeah but then he will take on d5
and Center is gone Bach will quickly
develop his bishops I mean you can't
catch take back of the night but you
want to please create some weaknesses
okay if you're going to have to exchange
that pawn you want to create some
weaknesses
takes on
yeah yeah that's the move he did because
he wants to create a weakness and yes he
won't lose the turn to castle but he
wants to at least create a weakness okay
no that move you lose the pot actually I
think after this it's it's extremely
quick it's just a tax if ninety five is
six and you lose the pond whenever you
push a pond to dip like this you gotta
make sure you have the reinforcement
ready you know because otherwise you
just lose it they need to look very bad
so takes both Winnick takes now question
to you how you capture back into this
situation Knight X immediately suggested
King takes other participants what do
you think King takes yeah in the end
games everyone the King belongs where in
the center right so if you take back
with a knight you're gonna have to move
that night back somewhere so you will
lose time and your king will still
remain in the middle but if you play
like petrosyan take later on you will
put the king on it too and then your
king is already not blocking your rooks
okay so don't be afraid to take with the
king if it's an endgame okay
remember if it's an endgame you can lose
your turn to castle so he goes Bishop e6
takes takes King e2 and 96 and I mean it
doesn't look that much this position at
the world championship level I mean this
is just an equal position but we're not
looking at this game because of the
excellent opening play of my direction
no opening was just probably very
conservative solid but we're gonna look
from here on how he's gonna win this
kind of position against a guy over
level of between neck very strong
technician and you will see how
Petrosyan will understand that this is
actually small marginal but better for
him we're gonna see this now and you
will see how he does that now white
needs a plan yeah
so what's what is he going to do now
what what would be the plan here let's
try to pass a little bit before we see
his moves and try to understand what he
can try to do here you can't but then it
creates a weakness you know when
whenever you're not sure what to do in
this kind of positions look at the piece
like a rook your rook on h1 right he's
got to come out no matter one way or
another right and rooks belong we're
open fast so that's instant move without
thinking you make a move because open
file you have a rock in the corner
nothing anything what do you do
put it up there both unique of course
will challenge you now he exchanges one
pair of ropes but keeps the other rook
in okay and what he is trying to do here
is trying to create a weakness on the
Queen side and a very important thing to
remember is when opponent has one
weakness
remember it's not enough to win you have
to try to create a second weakness with
two weaknesses you can stretch his
position eventually he won't be able to
defend so you need to create the second
weakness okay
but to do that first we have to get your
pieces active right and here he doesn't
just develop his pieces he jumps in into
the attack you will see he is hoping to
play e5 but what eunuch that can I do
that that's in a room his bishop so he
just defended because that's the only
way to defend and now he comes back now
he exchanges a pair of knights it looks
like what is it doing right look at the
simplifications
and I was b6 looks completely fine for
black disposition completely but he's
got an idea now let's see if you can
find petrosian's idea it looks
completely equally now in fact black
looks actively not putting pressure here
that's the only idea you have left in a
position absolutely you play rock v1
yeah but I I think I think the reason he
did that because he was worried about
black putting a knight on d5 here and
then you don't want to take because
connect the pawn structure so he created
weaknesses okay rook b1 threatened to go
before now yeah minority attack
absolutely but then he attacks you he
attacks you right away so a lot of
people in a position like this would
think about immediately moving the pawn
to play a three or to play a four okay
they would immediately try to do about
Pedro Sanchez let me see if I can
develop my bishop and see the
consequences so he was Bishop d2 if
black takes the pawn rook a one attack
tonight you retreat eliminate takes back
he takes you take and now he picks up
this guy okay
and a very difficult position because
look how weak the pawns are we're
talking about weaknesses how many he's
got here ton too many weaknesses and
that's it he can't do anything his
position is too stretched out okay
excellent
that's why he didn't take he went back
here now structure you got to put your
pants on a good square safe now what you
gonna do here what is the good move here
for black for white
he went a four he wants to put the pun
on v3 or even possibly played before in
some point okay if you play a three he
might even just play a five for example
so he goes rook c8 b3 this way you have
the freedom to move your ruca way you
don't have to defend a guy tied up so
bishop f8 keep things protected the Rope
comes to c1
he's trying to force the a5 move but
then a five would be bad because the
knight will be transferred to c4 and
then these two paths will easily
blockade these three paths it would be a
good block here Bishop e7 this was in
accuracy should've played Rock c7 or a
six or even rook c7 that way he is
better prepared against the following
white move what did Petrosyan play here
to take advantage of this question about
Bishop e7 move
ready five then runs into b5 he's got
the bishop a rule protecting it - yeah
but I'll take rook takes five let's stop
that I'm not yeah if little detail there
okay
so god I put pressure on the Queen side
okay pressure on the Queen side too much
liquidations now too much then we might
not have anything that's an idea but
here do you have a chance we have an
opportunity issue before of course
before of course before yes he can't
take with a pond rookie saying in Knight
takes you will eliminate it of course he
push he was hoping to use his cast pond
now very important move needed here for
you
pawn b5 fixing it fixing it and now what
you did is you disconnected his pond
from his chain and this pond is gonna be
weak but you know you still have to win
this position how how are you gonna win
this that's the question
so now goes king f7 what to do
relation between
Knight c3 yeah he but he will take you
Knight c3 is possible but what else else
you have here you want to try to win
this pawn this is a weak pawn now this
is becoming a target okay absolutely
or you can also put the bishop on d4 now
and then you go 92 you stretch you know
stretch attack this pawn so it was
Bishop a tree attacking the rook rook c2
and now he takes he decided to take the
bishop okay because white was gonna go
Bishop e5 he was gonna get more
difficult so he decided to take Luke
takes and he goes here
Bishop is a bishop it's a strong piece
in against so he is thinking maybe I can
hold this position now look see - and
King g7 it's not easy at all
I tell you this not easy at all at the
moment you know to see and proof you
know where is the advantage you have to
find a good idea here
it's an idea but yes that's a lot of
mousse so he might be able to do
something always on like a six in some
point maybe bring the King on c5 or
something do something what else you see
here his pawn on c4 is strong if you can
push his pawn force him to go down to c3
then he's not gonna be as strong he's
strong now but he might not be as strong
excellent suggestion attacking the pawn
and now forcing c3 because if he takes
you take now you put the King on c3
beautiful idea and now who needs the D
file we need the D file next will you go
rook t4 and then take the pawn this is
winning position actually so he does my
plate c3 now where is the knight
returning back to the centralized
location yeah no because he plays if I
you shut down your knight on v3 right
there yeah you're not going anywhere on
B 3 and then Roxy for okay for ya you
have to be very careful he comes in
check he comes in Luke d1 he goes here
now activating his rook take the pawn
the pawn is gone but now both linic a
wants the palm back he's not ready to
just lose like that Knight goes back on
he for now you're G to pawn is hanging
but see he doesn't even waste time to
defending he goes here so he can get to
look on a seventh rank rook on a seven
tried to give him a check King d7 cannot
allow that happening okay cannot allow
that happening on now he goes King the
seven
g34 protecting it Bishop to b4 now look
at that nice no no no no pani if I will
take you a pawn takes pawn your king you
have to activate your King to the
maximum pinky five get in there almost
checkmated there yeah be careful
almost checkmated look at that King f6
you don't see this too often at the
world championship level e no check what
is it doing how often you gonna see this
huh at the highest level the King March
to g7 but now the pawns are weak and the
rook needs to protect him he 5 he's
trying to get some square for the King
to go - what to do now
still not so easy to win this
he cuts him off cuts him off first okay
take away the square now I was here
black moves rook h1 yeah yeah now he
wants to be able to move this bishop
away so he goes king of some with the
idea of rook to e6 he goes here okay one
now Bishop has to move he's got no
choice he has to move now
he went bishop d8
check excellent when King said if it was
King c7 after kinky eight did you
realize what just happened after King a
the bishop is simply trapped okay
bishop cannot go anywhere eise evan is
takin f6 is taken he's trapped and if he
takes this pawn what you gonna do first
what you gonna do first now what do you
do check insert the check he moves away
and then you take it okay
insert the check yes excellent so that's
why he went king c8 and now continue
chasing that do you see how he is using
your king his king how actively he's
playing with the king here he's using
like a full force it goes here pin him
again if he takes who can see this who
can spot quickly the victory here one
two one two one two
nitrogen bid now check he just has ghost
King big you wanna put pressure on the
pin here but you want to do it quickly
so he doesn't have time to on pin the
pin how do you do it quickly here huh
one two one two excellent then excellent
93 95 temples yeah remember temples King
chess always appreciate temples attack
to it and then 95 will win this
immediately the bishop excellent
so it was Luke d8 stopping that idea now
we gotta get some pawns now because if
we win some pants then we can even
promote the pawn into a queen so I want
you to start winning one of the puns
after the pond okay excellent again
attacking the pawn on g7 so he checks
you because if he just goes here after
this he's going to be in sort of a souk
salon here well he has no moves to make
okay so he goes check instead where do
you go now
he's gonna keep checking you check check
so you have to do something so
check excellent the doctor pom and
that's it okay
and here in this position both winning
realized that he has absolutely no
chances he's gonna start losing this
entire he's gonna lose the entire King
site you know here and eighty-seven g6
and then he will lose because he can no
longer check then we just take the
pounds and if you play for example aged
sixteen ninety six you are pinned and
after the exchange king can just pick up
the pawns it's just losing losing
instant so after King g8 I believe this
was the last yeah I believe after King
g8 he resigned here he cannot even play
you cannot even play h5 because your G 6
pawn is hanging so you really don't have
any any any moves here to to sort of
avoid losing material here so that's why
he just you know there's just one line I
want to show you 96 so let's right he
tries to push this right don't trade now
fix him okay fix upon first so he cannot
move and now when he gets this exchange
everything and you pick up everything
pick up his pawns if your palm was up
there he will play a triage fold and he
would actually Queen so you don't want
that to happen then you take the pawns
and
yeah he can try this but he's way behind
in the race okay not even not even close
okay so King G it was the last game and
this was a very important because
Petrossian did the match actually
developed in the first game petrol shell
lost
okay so this was a very important
turning point because petrosyan lost the
first game and then ever three
consecutive draws and then he won the
first game Game five this particular
game set the tone for him and he went on
to then they went on they made another
sixth was no he actually went on to win
them they drew after this game then he
won Game seven
then there was six
of drawers they both unique worn back
[Music]
today lecture gonna be on a World
Championship history and I picked this
particular match up from 1963 between
Tigran Petrosian and Mikhail Botvinnik
Botvinnik was the current champion and
Petrosyan was you know the candidate and
he wanted the candidate tournament and
basically this was his chance and if he
didn't win it that year maybe it would
never be a world champion but winning
was a champion for many years so and the
connection between Petrosyan because
he's also Armenian and me and I went to
his school named after Petrosyan so was
trained in that school my first steps
basically I made it in Armenia at the
Petrossian school so that's how
everything started and the match was you
know 22 games total and that's anybody
know who won the match and well you
probably know who won the match already
from the hint that Petrosyan won the
match well war was the final score of
this match no okay
the match was won twelve and half to
nine and a half for Petrosyan okay it
was very difficult but winning was very
strong and his nickname is chess
encyclopedia he's extremely
knowledgeable he didn't play that much
but he would just analyze and analyze
and analyze and then he had a very
famous Boston in excess school with a
lot of the top list Kasparov including
lot of players went to that school so it
was very very unethical player so
petrosyan bought feeling both positional
players and the court of this match both
Winnick said after match that Petrosyan
just analyzed the positions deeper his
understanding was maybe different that
he claimed he also understand the
positions but Petrossian judgment of the
position was deep
like you know even simple positions he
would make it deeper
you know analyze it so that's what the
pitocin coated the match was played in
Russia Moscow and it was a huge
celebration when petrosyan won he was
the welcome hero and everybody went to a
report to you know meet him and he was
and the moves in the moment he won the
back turn there were no internet and
basically in the the center of Armenia
on a big demonstration board in a square
all the people gathered there like I
know thousands of people and then they
had this big demonstration important I
guess they would get the moves by
telegraph or something they would
somehow get this moves and they say the
move and the guy would go on with the
big stick put the move you know anyway
so it was really you know very long
match started in March 23rd and went
almost two months made 28 where
petrosyan won the match in 1960 and
became a champion and he was champion
for a couple of years and but winning
didn't contest it you know he's sort of
you know retired you know played after
that you know match so he was champion
for a few years and this game is game
number five okay the Trojan is white
against both Winnick c4 g6 night of 693
do you know the name of this opening or
question is do we even know which
opening is this yet
number of things so more likely to or
three yeah but it's we don't know yet
it's on no one at the moment there are
two major openings can occur here and
depending on blacks third move we will
know the name of this opening so if you
place Bishop g7 that will be Kings
Indian defense and if he plays the move
d5 which but winning did that is called
groom felt defense ok very sharp and
dynamic opening very popular nowadays so
Petrosyan was a player you know he
wouldn't go to the most sharp lines in
the opening now very conservatively try
to get some small advantage and nurse
this advantage in to win more
conservatively III you know try to play
three just try to keep the position
protect it castles Bishop it you
actually it's funny the system is still
played nowadays and you can still find
some strong players who will play like
this but not very proper this is
definitely not the most principled way
to play against groom fault so here many
different moves could be played is six
could be played which is decent c5 could
be played both vindictive so he's
forcing Petrosyan to move his bishop
again to recapture the pawn any place c5
immediately keep in mind back in the day
63 the theory wasn't as deepest right
now now even you know not a grandmaster
players they take
take
don't go Bishop d7 here that would be a
very bad idea okay and then you just
push okay
okay excellent and anybody has some
questions regarding our lecture today so
again the years remember the year petrol
sampled Finnick 1963 the score was the
final score was twelve and a half nine
in half or draws not counting five -
okay back then that's how they determine
the championship you know they would
play for two three months until someone
gets the magical five victories then it
was a champion okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]